I'm dr. Ahmed Kabul from the Institute
for competitiveness incidentally in
studio for competitiveness as a think
tank which was in the area of city
competitiveness and state
competitiveness so the issues that we
are really talking about today at the
forum they are from deliberations to
transformation I think it's become very
important that India actually starts
moving ahead there have been enough
deliberation in the past we've actually
taken it to the hilt whenever we have
actually said that there is problem of
the infrastructure there are issues
where the infrastructure in terms of
power electricity so on and so forth but
what we really need to really do today
is that we really need to put action to
the part that we have action to the
thinking that has actually been
developed what we really need to do is
to really take those steps the policy
actions need to be there if you really
look at the biggest issue right now it's
the regulatory issue and what we really
need to do is the government needs to
actually just push it forward take those
decisions and make people more confident
about India there is without a doubt
India is actually the flavor of tomorrow
India's actually going to be one of the
biggest markets they really look at but
what we need to bring forth is the right
conditions for doing business and to
really build those right conditions to
bring the confidence back in investors
the government will need to take steps
the business would also have to do its
own part of the story in fact I think
there is also an issue that a lot of
people tend to believe that everything
has to be done by the government but we
should not forget that businesses will
also have to take some action because
there seems to be something wrong with
the business models that people are
actually having in the country because
they seem to be exploitative and there
are various social issues that are
emerging so businesses will also have to
take steps to really create inclusive
models or business models when people
are involved so those are a few things
which would actually take care of what's
really going to happen within the
country and really move forward thank
you